alright much-awaited we missed a couple
of weeks of patriot mail because of the
vacation and a bunch of different things
that were going on but we are now back
on track with hatred mail and that's
what it's time for today we're so all
right it's wrong hatred mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom
all right this week's hatred mail
doesn't really need anymore introduction
than that so let's get right into it
you are fake news still haven't got a
story right you know how many coal
miners I know that voted for Obama when
he promised tons of jobs remember clean
coal as a typical lying piece of
Democrat he regulated them out of
business look at the voting map those
miners and coal workers and/or flipped
the entire election not solar you are a
joke this right here is why you are a
lifetime loser whole unions that is how
we won
muga [ __ ] I like Mogga that's it
enjoying that is right yeah make America
great again when I see it I think Magga
but I like that the interpretation here
is Mogga
I just like how he spells the word right
as RIT EEO that's not in that context
the right spelling yes because there's
like four or five different ways to
spell the word right and I think it's
just a lot easier to be consistent in
how we do that yeah I completely agree
with you and I completely advocate at
least when it comes to hatred mail for
that becoming sort of a uniform policy
going forward so what's up with this
dude I don't really know clearly at some
point about coal miners and regulation
and Trump is must be doing really well
at something although I can't exactly
tell what it is that this writer likes
about Trump clearly he was against Obama
for the fact that Obama was against coal
jobs did I really don't get this whole
coal thing where you have Trump
supporters saying Trump's doing
something great by revitalizing coal yet
they say that they believe in the free
market the free market is dictating that
coal is on its way out and you're
actually doing the opposite of allowing
the so-called invisible
hand to do its work by forcing coal back
in it it's very strange and there's a
total contradiction in that but anyway
this is probably not a conversation that
we can sort of have in an intelligent
way with this particular hatred but what
I can tell you is that you can turn
hatred mail into a good thing we have a
coupon code for membership which is hey
tree at 40 okay all lowercase all
one-word no-spaces h80 are IOT for zero
and you can go to david pakman.com slash
membership which is the number one way
our show is funded select any membership
you like six dollars a month two hundred
and forty dollars a year any membership
you like and then you type in the coupon
code hey tree at 40 and you say forty
percent that's a great thing hey tree
it's hated but you know it's good for
the show they probably don't even
realize what they're doing is
counterproductive and no and and that
it's the same way as the people who go
on YouTube and they watch down vote and
comment on every one of our videos and
saying that they they want us to go off
the air every time you down vote watch
and comment that's good for us
it helps our engagement in the YouTube
algorithm anyway I know I shouldn't tell
them this because then they might stop
doing it but I'm confident they're not
going to they really can't help
themselves or maybe it's just reverse
psychology that they're doing because
maybe we're encouraging them now to up
vote you know guys I would also do the
same thing I would not even pretend to
be able to predict what the rationale is
for anything that these people do but in
any case david pakman.com slash
membership and also patreon.com slash
david pakman show